more used to performing on their own
Britain strippers are now uniting on the
national stage with fresh union help
strippers on our fighting for their
rights
Stacey has been shipping for more than a
decade but has joined the united voices
of the world union after feeling
increasingly exploited we're seeing is
just we're self-employed and we make our
money and then leave
but we're treated as employees so we can
be told when to work we can be told what
to wear we've been told how to behave
and there's a lot of levels of control
but in actual fact that means that we
fulfil the criteria for worker status so
we actually have rights not a lot of
dancers realize how many rights they do
have Stacey's not the only one taking
action as 5000 women across all
industries recently took to the streets
to demand better pay and working
conditions Sheree supports sex workers
across the UK and believes power must be
shifted from management to the dancers
there are no strip clubs without
strippers the same way that there are no
factories without workers or officers
without workers and the power should be
with the people who provide the words
they should be able to claim their
rights they should be able to paint pay
fairly they should be able to be sick or
to have a holiday strippers have to pay
a house fee to work in most strip clubs
so it is unsurprising that some club
managers are reluctant to grant more
work benefits I wouldn't say that they
need to go as far as joining the union
but I do think that there needs to be an
industry set standard if there was a
board of or a committee that that
imposed certain regulations as there is
with our licensing committees then I
think that they should adopt policies or
enforce these policies on the venues
which will ensure that managers
especially treat the performers well
despite being in the early stages of
Union
sex industry workers are more United
than ever in their fight for a secure
future cumberpatch emo Scylla's